100 chess games I'm gonna say it again
100 chess games it's one of the longest
streaks ever without a loss and that's
how many battles dingly Wren went
without defeat an historic streak that
spanned from the summer of 2017 all the
way until November 2018. ding Lee Wren
collected 29 dubs during this record run
indisputably the Highlight was dingley
Red's victory over by jinxi if you
haven't seen it you might want to check
it out because it's considered by many
to be one of the most brilliant chess
masterpieces ever played by the time
ding was through his rating had surged
to 28-16 last time I checked that's good
enough to sneak into the top 10 highest
rated players in chess history there are
no easy wins at the top levels of Chess
we know this but dingly Ren is among the
most challenging against to ever try to
get a victory and he has no plans to be
checkmated in Kazakhstan